of course, the war in Ukraine is being drawn into
what we are talking about; deliveries of military
equipment are in progress; heavy equipment is now
being considered as an option for supplying
aircraft; in fact, today I
already said that
attempts are being made in one sector.
And so with the forces of two companies, with the support of five
tanks, in another sector, also one and a half
companies with approximately the support of two tanks
tanks are burning several tanks destroyed,
including leopards and yesterday it was the
same and yesterday there were leopards They are burning
F-16s will also burn there is no doubt about it
But if they are But if they are
located at air bases abroad
Ukraine And to be used in
hostilities, we will have to look at
how we can hit and where we can hit
those weapons that are used in
hostilities against us, this is a
serious serious danger of
further being drawn into NATO into this
armed conflict. Of course, we see
that
Western countries are making
maximum efforts to  in order for
Russia to suffer, as they say,
defeat
on the battlefield for a strategic reason,
defeat is done for This is all that is in their
power. We see very well that soon Ukraine
will stop using its
own equipment altogether, nothing remains,
everything they use to fight and everything they
use
is
brought in from outside.  you won’t be
able to fight for so long, I have many Jewish friends since
childhood, they say Zelensky is not a Jew,
it’s a disgrace for Jews